all right gianna hi gianna where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um i grew up in seattle washington i was
yeah i was born in vegas for uh i was
there for three years and then my
parents had divorced and so mainly grew
up all the way through in seattle
and how would you describe your
childhood
um
it was it was good i had me and my
little sister
when my mom and dad split my dad was
still pretty active in my life but um
more virtually just kind of like calls
every day
since he was in vegas he would make
trips to see us so a lot of back and
forth with that um but overall just
very loving very loving family great
yeah good good childhood good childhood
mm-hmm that's nice
and uh you went through high school i
did i graduated um yep excellent and now
you're how old are you now you're 20 25
25
and at some point
you started having problems with
your probably how would you describe it
brain chemistry
yeah it was uh kind of around when i was
younger um
pretty much throwing some crazy fits as
a kid does you know just uh my but as i
still got older my reaction to things
were
like a very very small issue would have
me
erupt i mean
i can i can remember one like about
wanting to
um wear something of my sisters to the
movies or something and she had said no
and i just ended up
freaking out canceled the whole night
like whatever you know things like that
that were just kind of like oh why are
you so freaked out about that and it was
just yeah i think the reactions were um
did not align with like the
event that was going on so it was just
this started what age yeah this was
probably around um 12 or 13 like and
because i had moved over to snohomish
for middle school in high school that's
where i'd gone
um and we moved around a lot like as as
kids my mom was you know single mom so
she was getting different jobs and we
were always kind of the new kids and
um
you know that was that was tough like
for middle school because everybody had
their groups already and so but i ended
up finding a place okay um but
definitely just
never felt like i had fit in and stuff
um so
uh that was just that's where the
reactions kept coming kept coming and
um pretty sad a lot of the times
so what was your
were your parents reaction or what was
there
um i mean attempted fixing it yeah my
mom was kind of like i my dad wasn't
fully aware just because he wasn't there
all the time so i don't know if he could
really see those reactions i can't fully
remember if i was like how to had an
episode around him
um
he's an italian guy so he's just very
like you want to i wanted to always be
careful about how i was acting
and um but my mom uh you know she
met a guy while i was in high school and
he had uh pointed out you know i this
isn't this doesn't look right you know
she's
that was kind of the thing i think my
mom was a little at that time it wasn't
um
mental health wasn't as like there was a
lot of awareness on it so
i think she was kind of stuck too i
don't know she really knew what to do
what steps to take yeah i think she just
was like
yeah you know and so a couple people had
to point it out and then that's when i
had gone to see my doctor
um
well they wanted me to try therapy and i
i just wasn't having it and i wasn't
clicking with the right person so i gave
the doctor a try
and that's where the medication kind of
came out so you tried therapy for a
while i did i met with probably three or
four and at that time i was just in
getting out of high school and had the
mentality of
well i guess kind of to backtrack that's
why i started smoking weed and like
self-medicating
and thinking it was gonna kind of ease
my anxiety and depression and i didn't
know what i had at that time but i knew
this was making me feel good so maybe i
should stick with that
um so that the therapy part again the
awareness was not there at the time so i
just had this thought of like
they i don't feel like they care to hear
my stuff and and that was my mentality
so i never really
opened up and gave it a try at that time
and then we just had to there was only
the other option was to go
get a doctor that could put me on
medication to
stabilize them the moods and tell me
about your
self-medicating your drug use
yeah it was just weed my senior year of
high school i got really into it um
i felt like most of high school i was
trying to i felt like i was trying to
fit into places and with people that i
it wasn't me um
i always felt off about that i made
great friends though i i still talked to
a few to this day but in that moment i
wasn't
so you know i i started smoking weed and
went with a different crowd my senior
year and kind of
backed out of wanting to be that
you know the i guess maybe the popular
person i don't know but i just took a
step back to you know we we smoked a lot
and just
got high i made it through high school
fine and that's the reason i kept
justifying the smoking is i just call
myself a functional stoner
and i'd just be like hey like i'm still
getting you know i can do this like i'm
fine you know
definitely wasn't smart i was just
driving around doing it all the time my
mom was
definitely aware of it it caused a big
kind of a strain in our relationship at
that time
um and then i did move out when i was 18
because i just wanted to keep smoking
and uh i was
that's how i was self-medicating for a
bit and i still did when i got on the
medication so i never
fully gave up weed which
i know was probably just a big mistake
it wasn't it wasn't helping so and you
started getting prescriptions for psych
meds at what age yeah psych meds was in
2016 or 17 i think um i know i started
with the general uh the prozac was the
one
that i started with um
but
the psychiatrist had
or the doctor actually hadn't diagnosed
me with anything yet it kind of was just
like a here you go like
you know my mom had explained the
episodes i was having so that she
thought the prozac would help the prozac
was making me feel kind of
wired a lot um definitely couldn't sleep
i was
very very amped up
and i was definitely trying to work on
self-awareness through this to be like
what what's working what's not working
so i knew something was wrong
and he had then
switched to zoloft
which then did a complete 180 because
the zoloft was treating more of the
anxiety but the depression was
there
so for me i like to think that prozac
was helping my
depression making me happy but
constantly anxious always and then the
zoloft was treating the anxiety so it
was kind of was going like back and
forth
and neither one of those were working
for me
and then that is when i met with uh
a psychiatrist that actually
diagnosed me with bipolar depression and
anxiety
yeah
and put you on different medications
yeah that's when i switched to
lamotrigine actually and which is
lamotrigine has as
they explained it was just like a a
stabilizer mood stabilizer so prozac
would treat one thing zoloft would treat
the other i was kind of dealing with the
middle
middle ground so that was like the the
stabilizer so
it kind of brings your levels to the
same
um and i think i
i think i started
unfortunately kind of at a high dosage i
think i started at i was about on
300 milligrams of low much gene
so during this time when you're
experimenting with different
psych meds and
and also using uh
other drugs as well or just um so that
was kind of the the other drugs came in
the picture after the psych meds the
lamotrigine because it was
i was still struggling um
and
again i it the awareness like i i didn't
know who to really it was hard to really
talk to people um and so
yeah i think that it was still making me
feel a type of depression and i don't i
don't fully remember my memories a
little
fragmented there but i know that um
around
the age of 20 i was that's i had gone to
um
molly and and cocaine and stuff like
that throughout a period of my time
because i was still depressed and still
trying to see what i could do to fix it
probably not you know uneducated there
but
yeah and what what what kind of
effects did all this have on your
relationships with friends and
and your just your
your mood yeah it was uh i would say for
a time i probably wasn't fun to to be
around i lost a
when i was really into uh weed before
because the molly and cocaine was kind
of like trying to fit in again you know
like um going to
concerts and things like that and
you know i
i knew it wasn't smart to be
mixing the two like an ssri and
something like that so
i was trying to be careful but it was
it was pretty dumb um but before that
when i was just smoking
weed and getting high all the time i i
lost a pretty good chunk of friends
because i never i i was so introverted i
did not want to go out i
turned 21 i had a little bit of fun and
then i just kind of
um
isolated myself from everybody and just
was getting high all the time so i did
lose i lost some friends that
um
you know
that was hard but
during that period do you feel like that
was the real
gianna at that point no it wasn't at all
and in fact it was like um
after the lamotrigine i was still
struggling
and i wasn't being very honest with my
psychiatrist which of course like
looking back i i should have been a
little more open about it and saying
what i was doing but
um she had a new
drug
came to the market it was like a latuta
there was commercials for it and stuff
and so um she was like well i'm gonna
i'm gonna put you on
uh i think 20 or 40 milligrams of latuta
while you're taking the lemon lamontagne
to maybe help you i think i was telling
her i was having trouble sleeping
and things like that and this was
supposed to to help that right
um
so now i was kind of double drugging a
little on the antidepressants and
uh the latuta just took a really bad
turn um
that was like
and that was only for
two or three months but i was i mean
i started like hearing hearing voices
uh
put me in a
i don't even remember being that way
before that drug like that wasn't how i
i wasn't dealing with that
and i was just hearing things i used to
have to sleep with the tv on every night
i had a roommate
i don't really know if she even knew
what was going on
and i was just
i remember i would have visions of me
just blacking out like completely i
could was almost scared to drive a car
because i would be driving and feel like
it was i would just
drop and and lose control i don't know
it was like that's what was going
through my head all the time
and i had a job at a restaurant
and i was always feeling
you know and i probably should have said
something and i kept kind of doing it
and it was just making me
feel even worse and worse so the the
weed picked up higher and higher to like
try to fight it and so i was
yeah that was like i think if i didn't
have like my mom
talking um talking with me and like
helping me i probably
i don't know like i don't really know
what would have happened
so um
that was the hardest one that i had to
be like i just had to tell
my psychiatrist that i need to get off
of this i don't think this is
right something's wrong
was there a time where you just just
wanted to get off of everything and just
try that again
to go just clean clean
not at that time yeah no i still
i still knew i i still wanted some
problems so
yeah
i was really scared and that and then
the thing goes with like i just didn't
know
who i was like i didn't i didn't know
gianna um
i was like i'm
not very in touch with myself it was
just very like kind of felt like
just a body kind of navigating through
life it wasn't like i could
i didn't feel i was making connections
with people or
i just felt really out of it for about
three or four years of my life i don't
it's hard to kind of remember some of
that but
um so your basic problems before the
psych meds were were
your overreaction to things and yeah
just depression yeah not
just not having anything in me to get up
and go i had a lot of
a lot of insecurities like you know
people in high school that
that's that's a was a normal thing and
but i was i was struggling with finding
my
my place in life and i was i just had a
lot of self
self-confidence issues
which made me
not care so much for myself so i was
like
doing drugs i didn't really
see
i didn't map out a future for myself you
know
and
so it was probably before all of this
was definitely just a lot of depression
not wanting to leave
my room or leave it was just
but on the side on the other side acting
very very happy to my peers and in
school and like outside and
co-workers just making sure like
i didn't want to be like the depressed
girl you know so i tried my best to have
fun and look like
everything was okay i just was uh
just what it just was going it was going
downhill you're in your early 20s can be
a time where
typically
a person will
figure out what direction they want to
go in in life and really kind of push
towards that were you
able to do any of that or you were just
kind of drifting i'm i went to um i went
to college i went to a community college
um and so i uh my mom was very
really wanted me to go i probably if i
didn't have her steering me down that
path probably would have never gone to
school
but again i i kind of picked something
to major and i i didn't know i i had no
clue you know but i
made it through college
high every every day you know i ended up
i did okay
but got my degree still was like
i i don't know you know like it was like
okay i got i got the degree that was i'm
grateful for that beyond grateful i just
never had i never had a plan for it some
people go and they're like they take the
classes i was checked out on a lot of
them
because nothing was really clicking for
me
um oh actually my last
my last quarter one of the last classes
i took was on medicine behavior and like
human yeah that one
was like [ __ ]
i should have done this i should have
gone down that rat and i still
contemplate going back and like
doing something in psychology and things
like that and that that class kind of
that was the one i was reading
everything and kind of reading about the
stuff i went through and
that was the first sign of like i didn't
feel like i was so alone i was reading
other people's stories
because again it wasn't so
out there people weren't very open with
their mental health issues um
i think there was like a stigma against
it so
and it also seems like the doctors don't
have a
really firm understanding of what drug
is the right one for
maybe a certain patient so they
experiment a little bit yeah totally and
that's like no there's there's nothing
against that i just think for me i i
ended up putting myself in a worse
position by trying to self-medicate with
other drugs and so did you have friends
that are
going through the same struggles
not at that time i didn't um
i don't think so i didn't have
i know i know one of my roommates had
struggled with depression too and we we
would smoke all the time so i know she
was kind of on that and i can't fully
remember if she was taking any
medication but
um
it was just i felt like it was just kind
of me to start on the journey you know
no one in my close circle
was kind of going through that
and definitely no one was going to like
therapy or anything so no one was really
telling me like gee i think you should
give this like another shot
of like trying out therapy maybe it can
benefit you more so i didn't have any of
that kind of guidance with my medication
do you feel like you're in a good place
today
yeah today is a lot uh better i i mean
still still struggle i've gone um i got
off of
pretty much all the the only
antidepressant i stayed on was the
lamotrigine because that one really
wasn't ever giving me any negative side
effects at all the other ones we would
try to work in
with it
was just not you know um
i was even trying to take after the
latuta and telling them about the the
voices
i was
i got 150 milligrams of seroquel
but after at that time when i was um
with my ex he had said like oh that
that's something they give schizophrenic
that's a schizophrenic drug you know
that they treat for schizophrenia which
i think was um
a misunderstanding because the the
latuto was causing schizophrenia so
treating
the schizophrenia that wasn't there
anymore with the latuta i mean i was i
was a full zombie i don't
i would take the circle at night and i
just know 30 minutes was set in and i
couldn't
move my body i mean if i was on the
couch i was staying on the couch so it
sounds like you noticed the effects of
each of these drugs yeah yeah that's one
thing i was trying to um pay attention
to the way i was feeling i was not i
wasn't enjoying it
so it wasn't fun you know i was
definitely like this this can't be right
i'm not able to
uh the one memory i have is like someone
was calling me and i i remember just
looking over and i i couldn't even move
my hand to get the phone call it was
like
9 30 at night and i've taken that
medication
and so i ended up there are certain
drugs you can kind of what i was told
was you can taper off of and then
there's certain ones that you can
actually just kind of remove and like
and get off of so latuta i didn't have
to like taper off i was like i'm done i
need to be done
the seroquel i had to taper a little
down to i think we took it by 50
milligrams and it was getting a little
better and then finally i just said no
you know never mind um so i got i got
rid of that so now it's only lamotrigine
i've gone from
300 milligrams to uh
uh 75 today
so
and do you feel like you're you're in
the best spot you've been since you've
been taking these spikes
yeah i think there's definitely room for
improvement still like room for growth
and um self work
again like when you say you're working
on yourself it takes
it takes work um it's not something you
can just for me i couldn't just depend
on something to fix that for me so
depression is a hard one for
like family members who just want to use
common sense and reason and convince you
that your life is great
yeah it doesn't work like that that was
hard too you know it was like um and i
love my dad an amazing man it was hard
for him to kind of see
that because you know he would
of course like i i reflect a lot
nowadays i think at that time i wasn't
really focusing on the things that i was
grateful for and the things i had
it was always just the negatives and
that's been my shift of mind change as
i've lowered on the medication is now
telling myself the things that i have
to be grateful for
and that was hard for him because you
know he would just be like well you
or you know the typical like you've got
a great life it's like yeah i'm just
battling some demons like i know i'm i'm
blessed i'm not in denial about that you
know i know there's
people out there that have it much worse
it was just what was going on in my head
was like
it it just was a scary time and i think
yeah a lot of people like it it's hard
to understand that when people are
struggling with real depression like
really of deep sadness that they're
trying to mask and act like
they're okay you know it almost makes it
more difficult for you
to hear everyone just saying no your
life is great relax yeah yeah i
definitely that that made me that made
me kind of stay quiet
i didn't feel
you know there'd be times um
another step i took too is i got off of
social media completely so i i just i
got off of it
and
because there were times that i'd want
to post like i need some help i'm
a whole thing and
i knew that awareness was getting better
and better and people were getting more
open but i just i was nervous people
would be like who is this did you feel
like social media is a
i mean we hear we hear that it's a
problem all the time but do you feel
like it's a serious
you know i think for it to each their
own like i think if um you're using it
for the right reasons and you've got
like
there can be very successful
things that can happen with social media
so it's definitely not to be like
everybody should get off of it and you
know but for myself um
i was not using it for the right reasons
it was like
trying to again post for the likes and
look like i've got this a grand life and
i'm happy and look at me when i'd be
typing the post in like tears
just behind the screen just miserable i
suspect they can probably make you more
depressed
yeah just acting and then you wouldn't
you wouldn't hit your certain amount of
likes and you just be like like ah like
no one likes me the whole scheme that i
was using it for
and i hit a point where i realized like
how am i going to grow each day if i'm
starting my day looking at how everyone
else is living their life like that is
very
i'm i'm um
holding myself back from that you know
what i mean because you can't it's hard
to
if you start your day by looking at
someone in the bahamas and you've got to
go work your 9 to 5 or your your job i
mean
that's not a good it's just not a great
start and so
since removing that i have noticed in
myself and
this could apply to other people too i
have just noticed the
drastic change in self-confidence
and uh
and like genuine happiness and just like
kind of living in my own in my own space
in my own bubble and like who comes into
it and who leaves it's it's just i'm
just navigating that part so
yeah i'm i'm
i'm very happy about that part um
and kind of in the the ability to get
get down on on medication but it
definitely isn't something that can
happen overnight it was a very hard
journey there were times i wasn't
comfortable with going down anyways like
i would really want to try to go fast
and
i had to take a step back because when
the lockdown happened i i was trying to
do that but again that was a very hard
time for a lot of people that struggled
with um that struggle with
any type of mental illness or you know
it's um that was hard to be locked in
again you know
that was still a lot of a lot of
drinking for me and like trying to
trying to self-medicate through that so
definitely wasn't ready and your mom who
you live with still
no
i don't live with you
i've been on my own i moved home for
uh actually i moved home
um gosh i can't remember the the time uh
not
i want to say maybe three years ago
three or four years ago i moved back
home because i did quit weed
because i started for
smoking weed for three years and then
the last two years of the weed smoking i
was adding tobacco on the top to give
that kind of that head rush
so
it was a really really dangerous thing
because you're just kind of smoking it
right out of there so are you still
smoking pot or using um i'm still
weed will be every it's just been
regulated more and now i've kind of gone
to cbd because i still struggle with
smoking that's the problem i still have
that like addiction to wanting to smoke
um so i've tried to regulate it but i'm
still kind of on that on that journey
you know you feel like pot is addictive
yeah totally yeah it's very hard for me
i i don't know a lot of people would be
like oh that's you you can get off of it
anytime i'm like huh
but i think i've gotten it um i've tried
to
regulate it so that it's not the
type of smoking i was doing in the past
of like i had to be high before every
single thing i mean i would try to go
home
because when i lived in my apartment i
was like okay i'm going to not smoke in
my car anymore because that's just
stupid you know then the dui like all
that so then i just ended up going home
i would go home before everything to
like smoke a bowl or two
and a lot of my family members knew what
was going on it was very obvious and
when i added the tobacco was when i just
kind of
dropped a ton of weight was very
unhealthy um
and the reason i stopped actually i just
one day i coughed
coughed up like some kind of black mucus
and i just remember i was 22 and i was
like
if this is happening as i'm 22 i do not
know what is going to happen in
10 years that's not that that's not a
good sign so i actually just bagged up
everything in a garbage bag
threw it over into a dumpster
and moved back home to
to sober up for i went about eight or
nine months how has your mom been
through all of this very uh very
supportive um like i said our my senior
year we had a little fall a little
breakaway um i was a little distant but
through everything
um yeah i probably wouldn't be here uh
without her that's great yeah
definitely not where do you want to take
your life now you're 25 you have plenty
of
yeah um i definitely want to do
now i see myself in a career so i do
sales now um so that's kind of the
career path i've been feeling like i'm
i'm
i'm good at um
i would like to
kind of get um
get into things like helping those with
um mental health like that's something
i've and so i've been contemplating
going back to school or maybe even just
using the degree i have to try to go and
and do stuff like that so i would like
to um
to do some help and i guess yeah i just
have a career i that's that's all i can
see right that's all i can see right now
um i don't have all the little things
mapped out yep stabilizing yourself
mentally is a big part of yeah being
able to think this way yep yeah so now
it's crazy yeah now lowering the
medication and kind of really stopping
the consistent weed smoking because now
it's just like
you know i mean
i cbd will be a little more often but if
i want to do like a joint or something i
try to limit it to maybe one twice a
week i try not to go every day and like
get into depending on it to like get
through the night so
with all of that lowering i just have
been like i can actually see
i can like see my future now because a
long all that time
i did not see anything for myself it was
almost like i
i would deal with some suicidal thoughts
but i never wanted to
i had all the love and support for my
family it never made me want to make
that that um
do that action but uh definitely was
like i guess the best way i could say it
is like i was okay with dying like at
any time because i just did not like see
i didn't see anything for myself so if
that's i guess that's kind of a weird
way to put i don't know but
jenna what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned through
all this
uh i would say the most important thing
just that
that working on yourself um
it takes work for
for me and it was just
it wasn't something that i could easily
do i think
um taking the time to figure out what
works for you and like all these
medications are still a mystery to it
yeah to everyone it seems
yeah and i i guess you know um again it
is like everybody's own journey and
maybe latuta worked for some people like
things like that you know so it's not to
say what could work for you what could
not
but just the most important thing i
think is like being in touch with
yourself and your emotions and how
you're feeling
um and
you know i that was what was worked for
me was my just being self-aware of like
how i was um feeling and
you know just taking the steps that you
can to
to work on you put yourself first and
i think that's really important
all right gianna thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you so much
wish you the best of luck awesome thank
you
you